all right park west fine art museum and
gallery is once again on the hunt for
the next great artist in las vegas here
to tell us more about the made in vegas
artist competition is brandon zado
brandon thank you for being here thanks
for having me this is absolutely
beautiful and before we get to the
artwork tell us a little bit about the
gallery you just opened up here in vegas
not too long ago yeah so the company
itself has been in business gosh over 50
years we're actually the world's largest
privately owned art dealer wow and so
just about 18 months ago we opened up
shop in las vegas and you're located in
caesar's palace right we use palace form
shops uh we've got two locations both
are towards the front right by joe's so
two different places that you can come
check out all of the beautiful artwork
tell us about what we have here i'm
loving the colors exactly so this is
actually last year's winner from the
made in vegas contest this is cat tats
so she's been with us now for
almost a year and it's been incredible
to see our international collecting base
acquire local vegas art oh it's so great
to see it all come to life and come
together and i'm on a mermaid kick right
now so i'm absolutely loving this
beautiful artwork here but let's talk
about the competition tell us a little
bit about what it is and how people can
get involved yeah so we decided when we
moved to vegas while our company has
international routes we wanted to
establish some local routes and so we
decided that we wanted to get local
representation within our international
company so we started last year with the
contest of getting somebody from vegas
into our gallery and the results last
year were just phenomenal we were just
overwhelmed with the response and so we
decided we need to do this again
and so now we're at round two of the
maiden vegas contest where anybody who
lives in clark county can participate
anywhere from drawings to posters prints
collages whatever it is
you can be involved in it wow so any
type of artist is welcome and what's the
process like how do they submit their
work yes so go to parkwestvegas.com all
the rules and regulations are on there
you'll have to submit some photos of
your artwork and then once we once the
voting ends that's when we'll go into
the voting process and you have kind of
like a panel of judges uh critique
everything and pick the winner yeah so
there's actually multi-layer of voting
here we'll have some employees vote
we'll actually have the public involved
in the voting and then at the end we're
going to have some celebrity uh judges
that are going to help us with the
voting as well wow so it's a really
serious process
serious competition i'm sure and isn't
it just so great in our community to to
showcase local talent and artists and
kind of bring this all back to life
again exactly the mantra of our com of
our company is art for everyone and that
does doesn't apply to the consumer it
applies to the artists as well we want
everyone to be involved in this process
and so that's why we really want to do
this well brandon thank you so much for
including our community into your
business here in las vegas and again
this work is so beautiful and what's the
timeline like is it open now it's open
now you have until july 24th at 11 59 pm
to submit okay that's when the cutoff is
and then that's when the voting process
will begin all right we'll let the
countdown begin we can't wait to see
we'll have to have you guys come in here
and show us the winner
thank you so much brandon park west fine
art museum and gallery second annual
made in vegas artist competition
submissions will be accepted through
that was sunday july 24th at 11 59 pm
you can also visit park west